I don't wanna wait forever if you don't
know this song yet by the end of the
world cup it will be living rent free in
your head
[Music]
higher higher Better Together was the
first track to be released for Qatar
2022 I got to meet one of the stars of
the song Cattery singer Aisha
[Music]
Aisha I'm so thrilled to be speaking to
you we're all singing in the office
higher higher higher but what does high
higher actually mean so the meaning in
Arabic means like let's go kind of it's
kind of calling people to get up and
um celebrate uh enjoy so that's like the
general meaning of the word
and when I first became aware of you you
were posting videos of your singing on
Instagram
how did you go from posting your videos
on Instagram to then suddenly singing
the World Cup Song
um I think it has a lot to do with
people's reaction to my music to my
singing
um for me I was just doing it for fun I
never like never thought that I would be
here just because I'm posting things on
Instagram
I think it was very rare to see like a
Qatari a woman singing online
[Music]
on your side
and I remember you walking out onto the
stage in April at the FIFA draw singing
your song higher higher
it seemed like such a groundbreaking
moment because like you mentioned
earlier we haven't seen singers looking
like you on such a global stage tell me
about that
um there was another life-changing
experience for me I just really focus on
myself focus on whatever Mission I have
to fulfill in that moment and I don't
think I just don't think I just feel and
that's how I would like go through it
and then when I'm done that's when I
look back at the videos and I'm just
like what what did I do did I really do
that did I just do that you know that's
when it hits me that like such a surreal
moment such a big achievement
when you're standing on stage and you're
singing do you feel that you're singing
for your country and for Cattery women
definitely I definitely feel like I have
a mission and uh it's not an easy one
although I'm getting a lot of support
much more than I ever thought I was
going to get
but it's still a mission I'm still doing
something that's different
um I'm still opening a new door but just
being that initiator for other women
it makes it worth it I'm happy to be
that person for other women I'm happy
when I get videos from little girls
um singing my song you know it just
gives me goosebumps it makes me very
happy because I feel like growing up I
needed that and I'm happy to be that for
someone else
get up and celebrate is the message of
higher higher but the impact of Aisha's
performance on the song will last long
past the final of this tournament
studios in Doha